You plan out your future?
I do. So I'm, I'm very go.
So I had that Accountability Mirror, but
I also plan on all my small, big time,
you know, medium goals, all these
things that have to do in life. Um,
I'm a big planner. I'm a
big planner, so you know,
right now I'm going back to scratch.
So I'm trying to be wild land firefighter,
you know, I did that for a couple of
seasons. And you going do that now? Yeah.
So I did it for, I did it
for two, not full season but,
but, but two half seasons.
So this year was my second year
doing it. I had to, I had to um,
stop about two months before it ended
because this book to start promoting the
book and started finishing the book up.
But I've been doing an opportunity
that's some fucking work, man.
Those fucking guys get after it made
you decide to do that. The work,
you know,
like when your hand stopped becoming
really callused it's time to get back to
work. You know, like I retired from the
military. I did 21 years in the military.
The military was my life. Loved everything
about it, the discipline of it. Um,
there's some about going back in the,
in the money you make is nil.
It's not about the money at all.
It's just about the hard work.
I've always been looking for those people,
like those guys.
Like you're out there digging
a three mile fire line,
literally a three mile fireline you're
cutting down, he's fucking shoes,
ash trees to dig his fire line and the
fire line, it's like 20 to 18 inches,
eh, for, for three miles. And you got
like fucking 12 people digging this shit.
And I'm either thinking,
man,
this is some of the hardest
fucking work I've done in my life.
And it's that challenge that you can't
find sometimes by going to the gym or by
running, you know, a hundred mile race
if that, if that new challenge of like,
hey and you get done digging, all
right, you've worked 17 hours, 16,
17 hours, you get your fucking
little fucking sleeping mat out,
shack down, boom, right down the floor
right there on the ground, get up,
dig some more. You know, it'd
be out there two or three weeks.
Sometimes man has doing that shit and
there's great satisfaction in the kind of
work that you do out there. No one's
watching. No one gives a fuck. It's hard,
dangerous fucking work. And you know
you're doing it to help shit out man.
You know?
How did you get drawn into that?
So I got drawn into it
because I was always looking
for the next challenge and I
was like, Hey, what is there
after the military with like,
what the fuck is it man?
I'm 43 I'm getting back in shape.
You know,
I'm fucking getting these health
issues for taking care of that.
I had and I started once again,
Google is amazing shit.
Hardcore fucking jobs. No, pretty
much, you know, hard, hard as fuck.
That's how I found the horse.
But the first race, you know,
hardest races in the world.
So basically I started to find this wild
land firefighters like what the fuck is
wild land firefighter? So I Google and I
start googling smoke jumpers. You know,
I'm like,
what the fuck these guys do?
What they jump out of planes and attack
small fires. Like that's the shit.
So I'm like, okay, okay. We could
put down a list and okay, hot shots.
It was a hot shot dude.
They go out but you know,
big fires and they dig fireline the I'm
like fuck [inaudible] I saw a video of
it. I'm like, that Shit looks
like it sucks is hot. You know,
there's limb know you're out, you're
on your own. I mean, you know,
you're out there on your own man,
just digging a fire line.
So that's kind of how I found it.
I'm always looking for the next challenge.
I'm never satisfied with, oh
I did that. Like, you know,
I became a seal. I was air force guy,
became a seal. I went to ranger school,
I tried out for Delta Force
twice. You know, like I'm,
I'm always looking for what is next.
Looking for those uncommon men and women,
uncommon people. Cause I'm trying to,
I'm trying to grow, I'm trying to
grow. And a lot of times, you know,
you won't be the only person that's making
yourself grow. You looking for those?
Cameron Hanes is those Joe Rogan,
those people who are like just different
people who understand what the fuck
you're saying because a lot of things
I have to say, I can't save them all.
I can't say them all.
You may not understand them.
So I had to really find
a way to communicate with
people. So they don't think,
oh my God, like what? What'd you just say?
So these Cameron Hanes is these job boy,
these people get it. So I go to those
little, those little nucleus spots get,
get a little more straight to get little
more knowledge, get a little more tools,
take those tools with me, putting my
tool shed and I go off gown, you know,
down the road or on a new journey.
So that's what I do.
Well the proof is in the pudding. If
you're really doing woodland firefighting,
cause there's no glory in that. No
Sir. No, there's no fame. There's no,
there's no one taking pictures of, you
know, and that paycheck is small. So
I'm a fucking Mickey. You
want to eat today? Wow. Yeah,
it's,
there's,
there's nothing involved in that
manner and they worked their ass off,
but you're just doing it as a challenge.
That's it does they freak
out when you're there?
You know what I think they're wondering
why is a 43 year old retired man?
You know, all this stuff you've
done. Why are you out here?
And I explained it to him. I'm out
here. I'm out here to, you know, to,
to learn from you all to grow.
And also to never forget
where I came from. You know,
that's where it starts.
It's that mentality of I'm going to pick
up that fucking Pulaski and I'm going
to dig this fucking fire
line for three demos.
That's that mentality I never
want to lose. I never want
to get so nice where it,
oh yeah, I did it, man. I
did it. I did it. I'm good.
That mentality of I'm going to pick up
that shovel and I'm willing to dig a
three mile line is there's some
about that mentality that I'm,
I'm ready to go to work at any time.
And that's what keeps me,
those are the sparks. Like, you know, I'll
look at motivation. There's just a spark.
It's like, it's like kindling.
You know how a big fire starts.
It starts with a little smoke.
It starts with a little cigarette
being thrown in the woods next.
He knew all California's fucking burn up.
That's what I've been doing my whole life
is I find these little sparks and once
that little thing takes off,
that's a, that's one hour of fuel.
Did you get tin are a fuel.
Then you can move that thing
to what 10,000 hour fuel.
These big logs and big trees that burned
for days and that's where you want to
bring that motivation.
That's what you want to bring that drive.
So if you have no kingly to Killeen is me
going out with these young guys saying,
Oh, I'm a fuck you're 43 it's a 20 year
old. Keep up with them that caming.
Now when I leave those young guys,
it has now become that 10 hour
fuel and now that 10,000 hour,
a few that I use throughout my whole life,
I use that term or whole life man.
Hey this summer at 43 you went
out there and you did that, man.
So you know you're not giving up
yet. You're not done yet. Not Today,
and not done today.
That's a crazy choice to make though.
Woodland firefighters a very interesting
choice. It is. It is. It's a nasty job,
man. Because again,
that's a proof of concept.
Like you're really just doing
just for the struggle. That's it.